what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and marvel studios is
really taking us in different directions
than we've ever seen before in the mcu
after the infinity saga they started the
new saga very very strongly with one
division then loki also took us over the
top and now moon knight is melting our
brains introducing egyptian gods which
we've never had in the mcu before and
mental illness and mark specter slash
steven grant slash jake lockley slash
moon night slash whoever the heck is in
there is making us question what is real
and what is not it's honestly really
refreshing the fact that we don't know
what the heck is going on is a great
thing and now multiverse of madness is
about to blow everything up so what does
the future of marvel studios and the mcu
look like which paths are they going to
go down and what do those paths look
like and where do they all lead to
that's what we'll be geeking out to in
this video so if you love marvel and
want to stay up to date be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos so as far as the
future of the mcu goes there's going to
be three different sections of the mcu
and some big bad villains that are going
to be the primary focus of what marvel
seems to be planning and here's the
really cool thing some of these sections
are going to intertwine with one another
which is where it gets really really
exciting also at the same time though
some projects might be completely on
their own and not have much of a
connection to other movies or shows
which in turn is great as well because
all it takes is actually one villain to
unite people that you never would think
would interact like thanos bringing
doctor strange spider-man and tony stark
together with the guardians of the
galaxy and at the same time a lot will
connect and build on each other and
finally what is this all leading up to
what's the next avengers endgame well it
actually all seems pretty clear when we
talk about the three different
directions that marvel is going the
first section of the mcu's future that i
want to talk about is the cosmic future
now this kind of got blown up a little
bit thanks to thor love and thunder and
moon knight but the cosmic section i
think is actually the one that i'm most
excited for with the cosmic side of the
mcu we're going to get movies and shows
like thor love and thunder guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 nova which was recently
confirmed to be in development miss
marvel the marvel's secret invasion
which will also cross into the grounded
side as well the fantastic four which
again could cross into the grounded side
loki season 2 and other awesome movies
and shows now as you probably could have
guessed by the name of this section and
by the shows and the movies that are in
it these projects will explore the
galaxy not just earth these are where
we're going to run into some crazy
characters like beta ray bill the high
evolutionary adam warlock and hopefully
fingers crossed galactus which we're
about to talk about in just a bit but
the cosmic side will be our out of this
world adventures and most of the heroes
that appear in these projects will have
some pretty cool cosmic powers or godly
like powers like thor and there's a
whole other side that we haven't seen
from the cosmic section of the mcu yet
that we're about to see in thor love and
thunder and that is the gods now we've
seen of course thor and loki and odin
and hella but now we're about to be
introduced to zeus and olympus where
many many different gods live so the
cosmic side is really exciting because
we're going to explore beans and powers
that we've never yet seen before in the
mcu now the next section that marvel's
going to go down is just as exciting and
it's kind of new and that is the
supernatural side of the mcu now one
division kicked off this section of the
mcu with the darkhold and agatha
hartness and actual witches and
witchcraft in the mcu and now it looks
like doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness is going to take it up not one
not two but many steps up the
supernatural side of the mcu is where
we're going to get our monsters our
demons our vampires and some gods that
aren't exactly cosmic gods i'm talking
about konchu and osiris and the lovely
hippo god towerette these are your gods
that possibly have some ancient
mummy-like characters guarding their
tombs trying to stab you with their own
bones like we just saw in moon knight in
the supernatural side of the mcu we're
going to see movies and shows such as
multiverse of madness blade the midnight
suns the agatha harkness show werewolf
by night which should be coming this
halloween and also whatever future plans
they have for the scarlet witch now as i
mentioned the supernatural side is going
to have some gods but there could be
slightly different gods than the
egyptian gods and gods like thor and
zeus and these are going to be the gods
that sort of rule over the universe and
have possibly created the universe one
could kind of put them in the cosmic
section but we know that it's going to
be doctor strange who's going to be
dealing with the consequences of these
gods the perfect example is the living
tribunal the living tribunal was
mentioned in the very first doctor
strange mordo mentions that he had the
staff of the living tribunal these are
going to be gods that kind of judge the
actions of certain people who mess with
not only the universe but the multiverse
as well and i wouldn't be surprised if
huge gods like this actually get set up
by the end of multiverse of madness
after all steven is kind of getting
judged for what he's done to the
multiverse in this film and then there's
the grounded side of the mcu and these
are going to be the awesome characters
like spider-man deadpool the captain
america 4 movie that's in the works
right now daredevil armor wars she-hulk
ant-man and the wasp the echo series
coming iron heart and the dark avengers
and of course regular avengers once they
come back as well these are going to be
your earthbound movies and shows your
kind of hand-to-hand combat fighting
sword-using gun shooting type of shows
and movies and of course let's not
forget webs but basically very grounded
movies and shows the falcon in the
winter soldier was a perfect example we
went from one division being about
spells and magic to the falcon and the
winter soldier kind of being a little
bit political and they use a lot of guns
and a lot of gear now like i said the
really cool thing is that a lot of these
projects can kind of be stand alone they
can exist within the mcu but don't
really have to reference it that much
because all it takes is a good villain
to bring many different characters
together and of course marvel is going
to be focusing on their villains as well
during the next couple of phases one of
course everybody knows at this point is
kang he's going to be making his
official debut as king the conqueror in
ant-man and the wasp quantomania but the
cool thing about kang is though he's
more than one villain really he's been
around for a while and he's got a lot of
different variants which means even if
you kill him off in one movie he's
probably coming back pretty soon but
he's not the only one hopefully dr doom
is actually coming pretty soon we know
that a fantastic four movie is coming
pretty soon hopefully within the next
couple of years kevin feige the
president of marvel studios has already
said that they are working on this film
and hopefully with that comes doctor
doom as a villain also hopefully with
that comes another villain that leads to
a really really big bad the silver
surfer leading to galactus all of these
villains have the potential to bring all
of these different heroes in the
different sections together kang
threatens essentially the entire
universe by controlling the multiverse
doctor doom has the ability to not only
threaten earth but become god emperor
doom and threaten the entire universe as
well and galactus is literally the
devourer of worlds he will be a huge
threat to the entire universe each of
these villains or all of them together
would definitely require all of these
heroes coming together to fight which i
think could actually be the next endgame
a lot of us have been thinking it for a
while and of course we are talking about
secret wars battleworld where the
multiverse kind of breaks and collapses
and we're left with a bunch of different
variants of the same people on the same
planet just imagine multiple captain
americas iron mans wolverines deadpools
spiderman all these different variants
fighting together alongside with all of
the other characters variants to defeat
a bunch of different villains i think we
all know that this would be a lot bigger
than avengers in game and i think it's
what marvel studios is building up to
especially with spider-man no way home
and doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness not to mention loki season 2 as
well but regardless of whatever
direction they take marvel studios seems
to be heading in a very very good
direction which is really a few
different directions which is nice
because things kind of don't get stale
and boring which is what a lot of people
feared would happen but the future is
very bright right now for marvel studios
but let me know what you think about all
of this in the comments down below what
is going to be your favorite section of
the mcu leave your comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching woof